this could easily
be the best burger I've ever had
start by seasoning up your bone marrow
with salt
pepper garlic
and get it on the nomad at 375 for 1h
cut up and grind one of the best quality
steaks you can find form your patty
then season it up
once that bone marrow is bubbling
we're gonna pull it off
chop up our onions
put it in the skillet
then fry up the best onions you've ever had
let's get our burger on the grates
we're gonna give it a nice sear on each side
then pull it
once it hits one thirty five internal
of course you need to toast up those buns
then it's time to assemble
with our steak burger
add on those fried onions
drizzle on some extra bone marrow
and think to yourself